brian austin green and sharna burgess
are expecting a baby these pics confirm
the happy news sharna showing off her
glowing baby bump during a trip to
hawaii to have a real relationship and
to have that chemistry that's not you're
not trying to create it for the show
it's there
this will be the first child for the
australian beauty and the fifth for
brian the 48 year old actor shares three
sons journey bodhi and noah with his
ex-wife megan fox it's 15 amazing years
that we spent together and three amazing
kids
um
and she helped me raise
raised cassius who's now 18.
so she's she's always been around i've
known her for a long time she's known me
for a long time he's also dad to 19 year
old cassius with actress vanessa marcel
in one of their hawaii vacay snaps brian
smiles as he rests his hand on charner's
growing belly other pics show the couple
walking on the beach and sharing a sweet
kiss
the 36 year old dancer grins ear to ear
in this kodak moment with brian holding
her up in his arms
hey baby
i can't believe this is for real
happening crazy i am unbelievably
excited to share with him something i
love so deeply the dancing with the
stars pro and beverly hills 90210 alum
first started dating in 2020 and when et
spoke with the couple last june sharna
opened up about her dreams to be a
mother kids have always been on the
cards for me 100 they've always been on
the cards for me um
so
you know we'll see what the universe
says will happen yeah it's just going to
leave that open brian even shared how he
feels about his kids bonding with her
she's great with them she really is
she's
she's super fun they love
they love hanging out with her and doing
things and she has a great connection
with each one of them but she's also
uh she just instinctually
sort of knows how to
not be a step not be a step parent in
that way but like really
just bond with them and love them and
they feel really safe with her and it
and it's it's an amazing connection that
they have and she again she has it with
all three of them on their own so she
she knows she really knows what each one
likes and doesn't and she uh she walks
the line really well with him i love her
amazing kids
yeah i was gonna say not a hard gig you
know what i mean it's not a hot gig
congratulations to the happy couple on
their little one on the way
[Music]